he grew up in an abusive household he
served in the war in Afghanistan and
Iraq he's one of the greatest endurance
athletes in the world he's David Goggins
and here's my take on his top 50 rules
for success vol 2 enjoy
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one reprogram your mind our mind
wants to protect us the mind is like
honestly it has a tactical advantage
over us it knows our deepest darkest
fears or insecurities it knows where we
start to feel we start getting that
doubt creeping that says hey man you
know what man maybe this isn't good
let's go back home to the wife let's go
back home to the kids this is not
comfortable so in that moment the mind
directs us it's a protective mechanism
it saves us for doing bodily harm or or
it really saves us from discovering that
demise like I want to be in charge of
you I don't want you to be in charge of
me so it tells you that's to stop right
here but once you start breaking through
that barrier and start breaking down
that governor the governor that you've
put in your mind because we forget we
are in control of our mind we believe
it's the other way around no we put in
our minds what we should do but we
believe our mind is telling us it's
giving us all this feedback we have to
reprogram it and tell us no no we're
good we're good we got it this sucks
but it's okay rule number two turn
darkness into power when you really sit
back at your life and you in that dark
room and you're looking at where you
started from
and you tell yourself God ma'am my mom
is this way my stupid stepdad got
murdered my dad beat the [ __ ] out of me
I can't read and write to say my soul
I've lied about it to everybody I've
cheated on all these tests my god man
and then you put a goal in your mind how
are you gonna feel man when you
accomplish this goal coming from that
coming from the hell you came from a lot
of people start from a good starting
point they have a good foundation what
if you can surpass all these cliff
everybody who was way up here started up
here and you had you started with no
legs he had a growth legs he would start
walking and then crawling then running
and then you start passing people and
all this give it to him I had to use all
this negative that was making me weak
and horrible as a person I had to use
this as the power that now fumed me had
to flip it on his head and say hold up
this might be exactly what I need
the darkness is exactly what I need is
how you look at your situation and I was
looking at it all up rule number three
visualize the end result I have the
ability to see the end before the
beginning even begins and what that
means is I know that to get to the very
end I can see it right now so before
with the buds and I lose all weight I
saw myself walking across the stage at
191 pounds got so I had to get to get
into the door I saw myself six months a
year later wherever is gonna take me to
do it I saw myself walking across that
stage getting that certificate of
graduation from buds and I was able to
be there at 300 pounds and that feeling
that I was nowhere near that feeling I
was able to put myself there a million
times
everything that feeling of like oh my
god that is gonna feel amazing that's
what made me suffer that's what allowed
the pain to be realistic this is worth
it I want to feel for this next 18
months get took me 18 months to find
become a Navy City family you know just
get do but 18 months is six months took
me 18 that's what woke me up every
morning was I don't put myself through
this much pain and suffering for a few
seconds so it is a few seconds of joy
it's so worth it man and so people don't
get so I'm able to put myself at the
finish line
no I have no finish line but at the
finish line of an event before I even
start them and say how are you gonna
fill it into this visualizing this is my
biggest tool of life that's why I've
been able to put myself in cold water
put myself in a hundred mile race
millions of times before I've done it
and I'm able to go through the race and
see I'm gonna feel at Mile 50 almost to
the almost to the exact Zac feeling
right so when it comes up it's no
surprise no surprise I've already done
this at many times rule number four
build mental toughness seal training
became pretty hard and a lot of guys
weren't getting through it so they
designed a seal pet prep program hmm
like a boot camp for the bouquet that's
right yeah and it was two months in my
last two years before I retired to the
military they sent me there to train
these kids Wow to get ready for you 9200
young kids so when they get to Navy SEAL
training man they were physical stunts
they were running swimming I mean they
were they were hybrid Wow
but they get the buds and the same
amount of people would quit why is that
this is why we were training bigger
stronger faster quitters hmm it's not
about not the mind
it's right we weren't diving in to the
sewer everybody's got a story we don't
share it on social media
we share our nice life on social media
we have we all have a dungeon on this
willing to talk about mine yeah most of
us don't really talk about it I'm gonna
talk about my dungeon I wasn't getting
into the dungeon of these guys mines
I wasn't building that so-called mental
toughness mental toughness isn't
something that you sample is something
that you live in every day so when
something hard would happen to these
kids like in hell week it would draw on
something that made them very insecure
and they look for comfort whenever
hardness comes and you know what it is
it may be different for you than this
for me but you go back to your
insecurities and then when you go back
to your Security's you then look for
comfort within those insecurities and we
all look for that cookie that your mom
used to give you when you were sad when
you were sick we look for our wife or a
husband we look for comfort it's in
those moments you must retrain your mind
hmm
to think differently in hell I wasn't
training them to do that
why weren't you training I wasn't
training myself dick because at that
time I was doing I was told these guys
need to be a standard physical stamina a
physical standard the physical standard
is not what they need to meet it's a
mental standard you must meet in life
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 254 series they're free the
links are in the description below you
will never learn from people if we
always tap-dance around the truth
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today what if I
can become someone that no one thinks I
can be and just that just me talking
about that I have hair growing up on my
arms rule number five take
accountability it doesn't go from like
one morning on this way next when I wake
up him presto the you know five steps to
greatness no it ain't that brother you
read my book this is hard work it's
everyday like right now I had to be
honest with you man I'm even shaking
right now being on this show I'm a big
time introvert how you address it is you
face it you face it every day you face
it every single day of your life where
you say okay like if you're fat you need
to lose weight it's patience it's
patience in this fact of accepting who
you are right now I'm fat I like myself
accept the fact if you lose 3 or 4
pounds that's a huge accomplishment you
have to live in your own world you
cannot judge yourself that's why social
mean always things are horrible you
can't judge yourself off of the
so-called competition that we have made
up in our mind the things that how
people look how people act awesome or
someone is this is a race that you run
completely alone and you're all by
yourself I had tons of sticky notes all
over
mirror it wouldn't like be better than
John or be as fast as whoever okay David
yesterday you did this today our next
goal for the week is this so I had a
year goal weekly goals daily goals
hourly goals and the big goals I lied a
lot growing up I wanted to be accepted
one goal was let's go one day without
lying let's go one day and then when I
would lie to somebody I would say hey
man
now go had to go back now an apology say
man I lied to you know how hard it is to
go back somebody say I lied to you
hey may know it back there I lied to you
dude that was really jacked up so I
figured out these ways of total total
accountability like right now I had to
run this morning before I talked to you
cuz why that's what about I'm about mine
mad body fitness a lot of folks talk so
much about hey I'm gonna change your
life I'm gonna do someone do that are
you accountable for what you're doing
are you accountable and I mean to the
tee for what you're saying I am and
that's where it started started with
that total total accountability of let's
not lie today let's tell people the
truth about who you are and when you can
get on and tell someone like I'm doing
right now exactly how up you are that's
the goal in life to put your life on a
billboard on the busiest road in the
busiest highway in the world and say
this is how I used to be
take it or leave it rule number six be
present I have to be very present and
everything I do like right now I'm with
which role I'm not thinking about but
rich role and with the canal your mouth
right now that's what that's what gives
me a huge advantage in life especially
today in this day and age with so much
going so fast and everybody wants to
keep everything going everything up and
everything I want to be the grace you
know the greatest multitask of all time
not me if I put my hundred percent into
what's in front of me I will destroy it
if I'm out here just multitask and I'm
gonna half-ass everything I do so that's
it is the most important thing the world
of me is being
August at the task at hand rule number
seven stay hard there's so many times in
life you don't want to be doing what
you're doing you can't just quit
remember this this isn't a hobby it's in
the jock it's a lifestyle so what you
say to yourself is important
there's no coach there's no trainer to
keep your doors only you so think about
this you can working your whole life to
get F and C at the table to see the
tables wouldn't be the best amongst all
the best people in your career field
so you finally get that letter it's
think lobster it's a big dinner
everybody's showing up dressed to the
nines make sure you saw soaking wet
getting after it working out hard towel
on your neck you respect the event so
make sure you put that towel over that
nice chair so y'all know the whole thing
is this don't say a word
stay uncommon amongst uncommon people
you're never done don't stop when you're
tired stop when you're done stay [ __ ]
rule number eight fix yourself first in
the book you tell people to make a list
of everything working against them every
real valid excuse right why do you have
them do that there's a lot of power in
that list so in that list of who you are
what makes you up all these are things
it goes back to once again excepting you
have to first accept it before you can
fix it a lot of people walk around oh
man I'm good I'm good no you're not it
you have to accept which you're not you
have to and people don't want to do that
that's the only way you can fix it you
have to accept it first before you can
go on the journey a lot of folks never
even start the journey my hand the never
start to join me because I live in this
fake life that who they want to be they
act like they are but they're not
because they haven't fixed all this
stuff yet you gotta fix this first
before we can start our journey in life
so that's why I haven't make this list
you fix these problems now your journey
can begin because you no longer care
about how people are judging you we when
you care more about how someone's
judging you you
gonna stay right there there's no
4-momentum so that's one thing about
that list rule number nine control your
mind
I understand that you lost some friends
and Operation Red Wings how did what did
that feel like to you being that went
through I was in three whole weeks I
knew a lot of the guys I knew every guy
that died on the operation so the story
touched me so much I want to find a way
to raise money for their families so I
found a Special Operations Warrior
Foundation if you're a special operator
and you die it will give a hundred
percent tuition to your son or daughter
to go to college great foundation so now
I gotta find something to do to raise
money for it so I started googling all
these different races I found the bad
water 135 so it's 135 mile run through
Death Valley in the summertime had no
idea about ultra running I'm 250 pounds
in a big meathead so here I am calling
the guy up on Wednesday goes hey you got
qualified for this race I go how you
qualify he said you gotta run a hundred
miles in 24 hours or less I'm like David
possible I haven't run over 20 miles the
whole year going through buds I started
realizing that you had to learn to
control your mind in these situations so
at Mile 70 when I was in the worst shape
my entire life I was able to draw on
being calm I was able to finish the race
rule number 10 commit fully I was a fat
guy trying to be a Navy SEAL now and my
life had come to this crossroads where
I'm like man you have to go right and no
one was going right everyone was going
let them like you have to go right and
to know that pain and suffering I was
about to endure by going right the
amount of accountability and failure
I'll hit the witness and suffer by
myself alone on this journey it was
daunting so when I finally got to the
ASVAB test and I'll take it for my very
last time to get into the SEAL Teams or
to try to see him try out they were
supposed to tell me my score and I went
back out to my car that took I was on
some computer tests and I know I used
computer
I was wigging out about that because the
first time I took it was like some like
notebook we open a scantron and you
bubble
with a number two pencil you turn in I
saw a computer I was like oh witness
with it oh my god like it's on a
computer so I wigged out there and I had
to get a fifty on mechanical
comprehension and I just like the third
time you've taken the test right this is
my second time so I took it three times
for the air force and twice for the
neighbor so this is my second time for
the Navy and they're like hey this is it
man you know you're done you're too old
you have a limited amount of time to
lose 106 pounds and you have to take his
vibe again there's so many things that's
crunched down my head and so when I took
the test I knew I had a good enough
score to get in the Navy but to be a
seal had to score high on mechanical
comprehension 250 so the first time I
got a 44 on mechanical comprehension so
I'm sitting there not take the test and
I hit Send sentiment it's out in outer
space somewhere and but I knew it popped
up at the administrators desk and he's
not supposed to tell me he tells you sit
down take your test and you leave I
walked out got my car or I was walking
around the car whatever doesn't I got
going to find out man so I went in I
literally sat through everybody taking
their tests nothing this guy he's
telling me I can't tell you it's against
government s rules every time he opened
it up it was okay man he said you got a
65 I said no man I didn't know I got on
mechanical comprehension and he Scrolls
the page down and it was exactly a 50
and I literally like what came through
my body because it's easy to talk about
now to you but no one knew the time and
energy I put into getting that 50 I put
everything on David Goggins to be a Navy
SEAL it's like going to the crap table
with with your last thousand dollars you
say no what I don't put everything on
this mom on black and hopefully I live
now I'm broke I put my whole life a guy
that would steer the water I got it on
us I've had a reader right on being one
of the hardest on the plan think about
that a guy that came from nothing I put
my whole life
and I'm gonna go out here and put
everything on David God has to be a Navy
SEAL
not to go be a you know Boy Scout or
some Navy SEAL and I look at that and I
did all this just to get the opportunity
to succeed that's what that's what
people don't understand man and people
see that the end result I remember that
guy say my god man I can't believe what
I've just done I put everything ruin
relationships ruin this ruin that put
everything on fact I have to become
someone in this world or I'm no good for
anybody
rule number eleven being open minded I
never thought in my wildest dreams I
could be a Navy SEAL
it's until you opened your mind
open-mindedness creates that we all shut
down our my like for instance when I
broke the pull-up record everybody
around me who heard the poor prick was
4020 pull-ups that's the first thing
they did oh my god four thousand and
twenty four hours or yeah it's four
thousand twenty plus two 24-hour period
uh yeah the first thing I did versus
closing our minds like oh my gosh Tracy
I wouldn't got a pin it happens every
minute exactly every hour every second
it's gonna take in life and make it not
to be this grandiose thing stop breaking
it down start breaking it down and most
of us we live in a box and we don't want
to go outside that box at all ever
outside that box is all these
possibilities of life but we do is we
shackled our mind we are a prisoner in
our own mind this is all I can do it's
all I'm good at and we we take away the
possible is if you could be this you
could be that you could be all these
things and I never thought it 300 pounds
I could be negative Wow
so if my mind was shackled me and you
would never meet there'd be no book
right there be no book right there'd be
nothing so but people are saying that
they live for themselves not knowing
that you have the power within yourself
to change millions of lives yeah by face
of life rule number 12 enjoy the moment
reason why we go back to old habits
because our goals are too lofty we're
not achieving our goals fast enough so
what happens is you know what man
we're very impatient nowadays for me
it was good I have a phone I was I was I
was out of this world by myself it was a
race against David Goggins it wouldn't
race against God I wouldn't look good
for this person to that person it was me
I got to change myself so for me if I
lost five pounds in a week I got a
feeling I allowed myself to feel proud
of that I didn't look I got lose a
hundred and six pounds I'm like man I
went from 297 now I'm 292 in one week
man I'm killing it we don't we're not
proud of ourselves for the small
accomplishments what we need is we need
this monstrosity of the thing that
happens say I did it now there's a
process that you have to go through and
patience is the process and if we don't
have patience after a week I haven't
lost 30 pounds and I'm done I'm over it
so that's why I found out with people
man they're not patient enough to
realize and to enjoy the moment not
living it just enjoy it
there's no finish line in life but enjoy
that moment Roger that man I lost five
let me go ten next week so that's the
whole thing about it that's how people
lose it
rule number thirteen change your
mentality you get the opportunity to
become a Navy SEAL and then you end up
going through buds three times it's like
yeah man I was very fortunate to go
through three times and not in this a
distich way in a life changing growing
way I found out so much about myself
through going through that training
three times and I went through the
hardest part of the training three times
you know after the first so first phase
is a crucible man and that's where I was
at for three times I spent most of my
time and buds at first base and the hell
week in the hell weeks and being in that
grind and in that grind I got time to
examine myself I caught the live autopsy
and also examine other people
cuz I was really good about putting
people way above me because I was I
wasn't I was never nobody so for me to
be on the same stage as these great
wannabe Navy SEALs and bus trained like
my god you guys are amazing actually got
here with you all thank you so much for
allowing me into play but as I was there
for so long I got a really good chance
to sit back cuz now the cold waters its
water now it's not our code anymore your
mind starts to change they said get in
the water most people think about it for
you
it became my life so I started learning
that if you start to change your mindset
versus it being like oh my god this
sucks I became a professional blood
student so I wasn't gonna leave until I
graduated so I started realizing if this
is my home this is what I am
I had to always reset the bar I had to
reset my new norm
they're always had to be a new norm so
one thing we don't do is we don't have a
new norm my new norm is you get up every
morning at 4 o'clock and you suffer this
is your new norm that became my new life
most people want to get out of it I said
no this is your new life this is who you
are you your new norm as you wake up and
you suffer and I started realizing if
that's my mentality
this [ __ ] ain't hard anymore for her
your new normal you wake up you're
getting the cold water you get beer to
the done whenever they say you're out
you get out so my new norm so I I do
that now today my new norm now is if I'm
doing the tours in my run your new norm
now man's you they're doing tour marks
the Roger that mentality that's it man
rule number 14 act on your feelings
I don't live on the surface of anything
yeah surface is what got me Ross at it
got me from a harness 95 pounds and 300
pounds telling everybody I'm good
I don't I don't give a damn I'm good no
they're they're hollow words mmm a lot
of us speaking hollow words I used to
speak in hollow words I don't do anymore
everything that comes out mouth has
substance it's real and we all have
these feelings in our bodies in our
minds and our souls I act on mine
a lot of us who are afraid of something
we allow our minds to choose the path of
least resistance or to go a different
route I'm afraid of something is telling
me you must do this thing you must do
that yeah you have to go that way and
most of us don't understand that
mentality we go left and we wonder why
we haven't fulfilled something in their
lives it's because we continue to take
the journey that is mapped out and how I
look at it is I I talk in life like a
lot of us in life want to take the
four-lane highway that has road maps and
all this other stuff on it man tells you
where to go gas stations the next 10
miles up you can see a McDonald's a
Cracker Barrel yeah it's the easy route
very few words gonna go to the right
side
rule number 15 adapt to the suck a lot
of us dream big you should dream big
dream big is important you know some
toys won't be doctors lawyers dentists
towards money I want one of these
special operations so you have this big
dream you can see so clear like it's
right in front you can go out and touch
it
but the thing about it is somewhere if
you dream big enough somewhere down that
journey that dream becomes a nightmare
and what happens in that nightmare so
they have all these questions like if
you want to be a special ops you may not
be a great swimmer you may just realize
that I'm not great some out I'm not
great runner you may start to fail tests
and all these questions start to flood
your mind why am I here I'm not good
enough trust me I know all about the
questions they will flood your mind if
you do not have the answers for them you
will quit the answers lie in the
repetitions you must not forget the
repetitions you put into trying to
dominate the crap that you're in today
always always embrace the suck adapt to
the suck rule number 16 use your cookie
jar when you're afraid of something you
have to master it that's how you start
to overcome it so what I realized when I
get to that point where I want to quit
everybody they get the point where I
want to quit this is what happens the
mind tells you let's go home let's take
a warm shower let's get some food this
is not right this is that
if you cannot answer the questions at
that moment because your minds gonna
start giving you all these questions all
these questions and if you can't answer
them you're going to quit what I
realized when I was going through buds
Ranger School all this hundred mile race
towards at my races pull-up records my
mind would come creeping in like I was
doing four thousand thirty poops that
two thousand pull of us in my hands are
ripped open my mind said look brother
we've done all these other things you've
proven yourself you're good if I didn't
have the answer to respond to my mind
and say why I'm here why I'm doing this
you will always lose that fight you have
to have the response to what your mind
is gonna tell you and another thing
about that is self-talk
a lot of people have like these big four
on mental toughness all this crap about
self-talk visualization it's true but
the thing about self talking all these
things they asked me what do you think
about when you're on mile 100 of a tours
and a five mile run what are you
thinking about when you realize you've
run for 24 hours and you have 24 more
hours to run and yet another hundred and
five miles what goes through your mind
what do you say to yourself I want to
know a lot of people think self-talk
works it does but doesn't work without
the suffering before your mind starts
saying we need self-talk so what I tell
myself is I go back to the months and
years of preparation to get to that day
now I'm telling myself the 3:30 in the
morning and I'm looking at my shoes and
I want to go out there and run 30 miles
I have to in that second in that moment
of this self-talk my myosin you got to
find more you gotta find more I once
again calm down go back into my mind and
my cookie jar I call it and I had to
reflect back on this idea to get here
and that becomes my self-talk self-talk
does not work unless it is real most of
us lie to ourselves in the self doesn't
work it has to be real has to be
something that you've done to make it
really work
number 17 live your life to the max we
want you the most well huh me most is
that if I would have died at 300 pounds
let's say uh 75 years old I got to
heaven and God has a chart like that on
everybody's life God knows all let's say
that I don't care what you believe in
doesn't matter I'm not judging anybody
let's say my thing is God you get to
heaven on fission pounds I sit down I
was a cockroach terminated my whole life
and we're sitting down just like this
you're God and I'm David and he gives me
that chart and he says look at this now
look at this chart and on the chart it
has all these different things but my
names on it but these things aren't me I
was going to change the world I was
going to be I'm gonna set records I said
be a Navy SEAL it's gonna be all these
things the military that I accomplished
you ever get to VFW award you could be
honored here honor dare I'm like God I
was this isn't me like it says David
Goggins I was a ecolab guy sprayed for
cockroaches and I'm 300 pounds to here
I'm 185 it says here I got a bachelor's
and a master's it says all these things
and God goes no that's who you were
supposed to be Wow my biggest fear in
life is that there is a final resting
place in this world and there's a final
judgment and you talk to something much
bigger than you I don't want to sit down
and have a conversation with someone
with something that says you're in
heaven this is what you should have been
on earth and are you really in heaven
now are you in hell
mmm thinking about how much I left on a
table for fear for not willing to go
over the wall and over the next wall and
over the next wall so my mind I believe
that and God knows all at least I
believe that I want God to be up there
right now as we're speaking writing
stuff down saying my god he exceeded
even my expectations that's how I live
my life I now know that there is no cap
on the human mind
there's no cap we cap it ourselves
rule number 18 take souls when you grow
up weak and you start to master your
mind because my whole thing is whenever
I'm whenever I'm weakest something
wherever I'm scared of something I
master it I was a weak ma you know a
weak-minded person so I mastered my mind
and it matched in my mind I mastered the
human mind and I realized why I'm no
longer just people why I don't like I
put people on a pedestal cuz we're off
up around way we all have demons some
people hide them better than other
people
so I know we all have them by me knowing
that under the most alpha males are very
fragile very fragile they never want to
see another person harder than them
especially in that kind of grand ego
attached to ego are very strong ego will
forgive every time ego was serious so if
I can hurt your ego I got you so by me
having such a fragile ego growing up all
this was my event I was doing a live
autopsy on a stop I was okay this me up
I've been telling people to so I start
using all these different tools and
tactics to getting the structures heads
and taking souls that's where it
happened man we were Wednesday freezing
cold
everybody's jackhammer and everybody's
everybody wants to you know everybody's
just want to get through it now
jackhammer ends when you just can't stop
she can't stop shivering you know you're
sitting this uncontrolled be
jackhammering and the instructors take
great pride in watching you suffer they
do we're you know in in a sick way it's
kind of funny you know you know you were
there once as a student now your
instructor but I knew how would I be
think if I was in destruct I would love
seeing this sadistic go on but what went
out what wouldn't I like to see I would
hate to see some guys just looking like
this is just another day on the beach
and go for yourself I would hate to see
that so I don't want to think like that
when they did it they were harder they
were harder yeah everybody's horse I see
know what man it's time y'all I can't
fight you you guys can me up all day
long that's your job and I love your job
I love what you guys are doing you guys
making us better but now I want to take
the tactical advantage and I'm gonna
start with you so
got my boat crew Bill Brown I had Chris
Kyle on my boat crew American I've had a
couple of horrorcore and everybody right
now is kind of like in their own world
let's just get through this man I can't
wait til Friday so we can graduate how
we can get going I said let's go ahead
and have some fun I said we're gonna
stuff with these guys so the evolution
here was we got to with Matt check you
know we're stripped down to nothing and
they're checking us out making sure
we're good to you know checking front of
Mon your second from Japanese my knees
all jacked up but they're giving me
shots and she and I would like to boat
crew leader of boat crew to so I'm in
the front of boat and I tell our guys
this we're gonna do the boat like on our
heads salt was we're supposed to lift
the boats up above our head sorry god
dude
but when you're this week in this
fragile II this tired their boats heavy
so there's a thing you can do when you
do boat presses so you can get the boat
and like just toss it up toss it up and
catch it that show is like you're jacked
up
so everybody's holding the boat and
they're shaking and they both start to
come down their head and all the boat
crews are all lined up and their stuff
now I'm looking at that and I turn
around my book I said guys it's time to
take some Souls anybody talking about I
said we realize this truckers out here
all on their jackets and freakin coffee
and laughing and smiling I want their
faces to go straight up numb so we're
gonna do this we're gonna start boat
pressing this money just take my lead
trust me you'll get energy from it we
start don't us boat up in the air cash
the toilet for Cassandra Tatiana can't
hurt no crew to wear your own ass off
and we do it and they make a stop like
what the like to stop I look at these
instructors and their faces
literally look like someone like just
like - they're so loud no other minds
were like they were thinking about
themselves like what just happy man I
know me always that couldn't done that
how they doing it so the rest of time
going through hell week it was like we
just you know that we owned it right
boat crew - we won every single race we
were just dominating and it was uh
there's a strong boat crew and that's
we're taking souls is uh there's a few
taking soil stories but that's one of
them rule number 19 used suffering to
improve a lot of us don't know of a
whole nother world that exists it's on
the other side of suffering once you
break these barriers that you have made
for yourself like the mind is the most
powerful thing in the world in the world
it is so amazing the ice would be a
300-pound guy and I thought that was it
could barely read could do anything and
now that what was inside that person was
this guy that's in front of the day
that's how scary the mind is and that's
why I started realizing through this
journey is that once I got a taste of
wow man I haven't even cracked I haven't
even begun to crack what the mind is
capable of and when I started realizing
there's only other end of suffering
that's the real growth of life because
you realize how the mind processes and I
talk about another thing called theory
and practice a lot of people are
theorists they these smart guys that
read these books and man and they sit
down they tell you what their mind is
supposed to do and a lot of us listen to
that it becomes like this is it man this
this old man who has been studying the
mind forever
this is the cap that we have by being a
practitioner I wouldn't out and realized
a lot of these guys are so wrong man the
mind has capabilities that are so
unknown I found that through suffering
and there's a whole nother world on the
other end of that rule number 20 do
whatever it takes 27 years ago on that
spot and was gas me a question yesterday
was a question he asked if you're paying
the price physically now for
you put your body through if I pay the
price so max was yes I am but what he
didn't know was literally I stepped back
at 297 pounds Luke the accountability
mirror I saw a flex night like it wasn't
so much the outside there's a lobby
inside so that bothered me and I was
going to do whatever it took to change
that reflection you gotta find out what
you want to do to change reflection that
accountability bear rule number 21 take
accountability one big thing is the
accountability mirror mmm you have to
start with yourself so what happened in
my life was we start to get I call it
like the rucksack a rucksack is a pack
that you carry in the military and you
put all your stuff in it your radios
your food your water all that stuff you
have to carry in the military that's
your rucksack it's a backpack pretty
much as you're growing up we all have a
backpack most of ours hopefully is empty
you know and what we put in it is all
the crap we go through in life that's
what is in the backpack for the
civilians and we carry it around with us
so what you have to start doing is
realizing that no matter where you're at
in life I got called [ __ ] a lot
my dad abused me you know learning
disability stutters immaturity
insecurities self-doubt so much crap on
top of me so much stuff I lied a lot to
create friends so people so much stuff
was in my backpack no one's coming back
to help me so it starts with that person
in that mirror you have to realize you
are on your own now and whatever else
you believe in I don't care what you
believe in but on earth it's a very
lonely journey it starts with the
accountability mirror of looking at say
hey my daddy beat the hell he's not
coming back all these things are coming
back I have to face myself and you have
to own all those things that people may
have done to you now it's yours you got
to own it it's yours now to fix the
problems that people did to you it makes
no sense it's not fair I get it but if
you live in that what was my mentality
of
guess what my dad did this to me my mom
just did to me people who bully did this
to me you're gonna always live right
there you have to figure out ways to
move forward because it's not coming
back it starts with the mirror and I
call it the accountability mirror in the
book
rule number 22 being open minded if you
walk into any kind of event whether it
be physical or mental if you walk in
with already putting that block on your
mind if man this ain't gonna happen
people go how did you gonna hurt 35
miles to death badness so hide you 100
miles with no training because I went
into it not thinking I can't do this man
I went to it with the strategy I had an
open mindedness so until your mind is
open to the possibilities that I can do
this you would never be able to do it
once the mind starts to believe it can
be achieved it then only then that it
starts to break down tactically how we
can do this until then you can always
lose
rule number 23 stay in the fight there's
energy all around us but we think that
we have to have asked to come externally
a lot of times we have like a TV in
front of us watch some by listen to a
podcast listen to a great music a lot of
times in life is quiet and those are the
times when you want to run and hide you
got to be able to find energy you got to
make up games makeup tricks makeup
whatever you can to get to the next
evolution of life so taking souls is
just another way it's not about hurting
the person you're against it's about
finding the tactical advantage in every
situation you physically can to get to
the next you're trying to inch further
to the goal line and you don't want to
what is that goal line the goal is
whatever it is for you for me I want to
get to hell week I don't get to help
with you know with my head up high
being strong I don't know what the goal
line is for everybody
my goal has been very different for most
people but you're trying to find energy
and strength to stay in the fight to
continue on until you get that second
wind the second win is
whenever ii win maybe for you it's
coming but what happens is we get so
stressed out that the end is so far away
that we just can't find another foothold
another hand hold so we jump off the
cliff from his fall rule number 24 on
your mind well life took me somewhere
unexpected I'm unprepared I'm just about
six degrees out here and I'm
underdressed but guess what no one gives
them okay get them sometimes life can
really hijack your mind when that
happens to you you're all dumped your
goal is RAM [ __ ] is everything is out
the window
in life we all go to different things
sometimes your girlfriend or boyfriend
breaks up with you guess what get the
[ __ ] over it then no longer wants you
maybe you fell a test in school you
worked your ass off guess what you
failed the test get over it move past it
learn to not let life hijack your brain
at work you've been working your ass off
for that new promotion you don't get it
someone else does
maybe they kiss better ass than you do
guess what get over it life will hijack
your mind if you let it don't allow all
these things to make you a lesser person
you must own your mind don't let life on
yours
rule number 25 figure out your purpose
once you transform yourself and even
though I'm still I'm not running from
myself I'm constantly facing myself I'm
constantly battling myself I'm not
running from him anymore I used to but
now I'm constantly battling them so now
what happens is once you get to port in
your life where you're able to be on a
podcast to be on a TV show and tell
everybody I'll step you are I will
answer any question you want about me
anything I did anything bad good ugly I
will tell you when you get to that point
in your life that's where your real
journey begins and you no longer have to
have a small victory to keep you going
you now realize what your purpose in
life is and you realize all this is just
part of it but at first you need all
these different tactics to keep you
going because you haven't figured it out
yet once you figure out that you're in a
race amongst billions of people that
live in this world you're in a race by
yourself you have a purpose and it's
your purpose
about the purpose it is your purpose and
only your purpose and it's your race so
then you're like hey ma'am I'm doing my
thing I'm doing the best of my ability
what's next there's no longer these
small increments to get through life
because once you figure out why you're
here
it just becomes a process rule number 26
be prepared for anything
talk about mr. Dobbs he's a good friend
of mine still to this day and he went
into that place man and I knew where he
was going is it my throat hell week and
I knew Sean real well but I knew he was
real arrogant he had a serious chip on
his shoulder like I do I still do I got
that controlled every night and it got
me in a lot of trouble sometimes but I
knew he had it
I knew that chip on your sword not being
controlled it will it will get you up in
it and it cost him a lot going through
buds and I saw the look I saw the look
because I once had to look when I was
going through a rescue school when
something got so hard and your mind
can't process the hardness you don't
know the the the right tools to get
through something hard because you've
never been challenged before I could
tell he was a superhuman that nothing
never challenged them but I knew because
I've been through hell week a couple of
times I knew don't don't underestimate
that it will it will find a demon it
will bring out some insecurities in you
and it did and I it was like maybe 30
hours in the hell week or something like
that I'm looking over at him and I
smiled at him where we're standing just
like this in line and he's getting his
man check at doctors looking at him a
doc that happened this to be beautiful
timing and I'm sitting there I'm getting
mad checked and I'm looking at him and
his eyes says he's a thousand-yard still
looking right through me he's getting
mad checked and I'm looking at him and
before this happened I told him I said
don't underestimate this man he was I
can't ever see myself quitting Goggins I
go to watch out I go watch out I guess
we'll get in your head I go the end is a
long way away so we're sitting there I
die and he didn't see me and I'm right
in front of him and I could tell you
thinking here's that quitting mind
starting up now look at him I go I told
you
I told you the next thing I knew ma'am a
car pulls up and um he he rolled out
rings a bell he rings to Bill and he
quits but uh it was uh he's a great
human being
harden it it doesn't make you you know
when you quit something like that man
it's a huge lesson learned that I can't
go into anything thinking that there's
nothing that's not gonna get in my way
you gotta be prepared for all those
obstacles room 427 being courageous when
I picked up your book the thing I loved
about it is the amount of effort that
you've been through to give us I'm sure
this was suffering through like writing
this book the amount of effort that
you've been through to actually give us
detail right on your life we all have
different things in life that have
scarred us we want to act like those
scars don't exist a little scars like
you know if you go out and you get cut
that scar is gonna be there on your arm
you can go down and look at that cut and
say Oh or that scar and say oh that
happened from you know I was in the
kitchen what would happen we have the
same thing on our brain I have all these
scars on my brain from growing up from
you know being abused from suffering
through life from having to learn
disability from stuttering from having a
just a really bad childhood and so all
those memories either cut open that scar
and go into it and that was a hard
process for me to do not only was that
hard process me do for me to have the
courage to share that with people you
know because I'm the so-called toughest
man on the planet so they think so for
me to break open that shell and tell
people hey that wasn't always me you
know it is it's hard to do you know it's
hard to do so it was a tough process
throughout this journey I started
becoming this new person I saw like
creating this new person the people
started seeing me as this amazing
superhero in the back of my mind I knew
the real story that I was like man one
day you have to really share it I'm like
man but do you have the courage you know
like it's great to live right here I've
established as people think you're great
just stay here don't go back let's not
go back but the only way you can help
people out is let them know that this is
possible so I had to go back and say
this is where I come from yeah and where
I come from is hell
rule number 28 continue to challenge
yourself all this that went through my
life to get here today
it is tattooed it is tattooed in my
brain every day I wake up I am
constantly battling that person that is
like man you know back in the day this
happened to you man
you know like you got called [ __ ] so
many times and your dad beat the [ __ ]
out of you man and you know you couldn't
read in this daggone junior year all
these things start to creep up even now
where you're at today every day you're
having to constantly battle it's not as
bad as it used to be by any means but
that person still there is that person
always lives and that's the that's the
point about you have to continue to
always challenge yourself every day
rule number 29 ignore the noise the one
thing I'm most scared of in the world is
losing losing touch with the the best
thing the world is is your mind your
mindset how you can picture yourself how
you can focus how you can drive how you
can put yourself in so many situations
get out of it because those headphones
you're listening to those those phones
that that we google to find information
there's so many situations in my life
with a it's not gonna help me it's not
gonna help me and you're able to just
turn that off so fast because I know
please help me none of that stuff is
ever helped me
mm-hmm none that stuff Sarah helped me
would has helped me has been me alone
getting my SH together and being
accountable for who I'm not and who I
want to be so again it's helped me rule
number 30 examine yourself I coach a lot
of people nowadays billionaires could
call me on the phone and said man I'm
still missing something it's because
they did what they were good at and they
have this beautiful family
two three houses cars everything has
everything that weren't on the outside
looking like my god I mean how can you
be unhappy I walk around with the
backpack with all my stuff in here have
no car right and I walk around
happiest personal world have nothing
happy as hell it's because I found out
the whole key to life it's not in all
that you have to face yourself so many
people live to be a hundred years old
and they die miserable having everything
because they never examined I caught my
live autopsy mm-hmm
you never examine this happiness peace
enlightenment it's all up here man it's
all up here and I start talking like
this people man you know no no it's the
truth man yeah that is true it's all up
here
he's getting to go and face it that's
the hard part
rule number 31 have a brutal work ethic
you don't need to have this humongous
GPA and all the third [ __ ] which you
need is the one thing I talked on my
book was just straight-up brutal work
ethic you have to be willing to outwork
everybody in the world and that that
that's the hard part that's the hard
part this isn't like some five step
process where you can do these five
steps you're gonna end up with this
magical world now I'm basically teaching
you how to callus over your victims
mentality I'm teaching you how to like I
did 67,000 pull-ups and training for the
pull-up record I was seriously calloused
in my hands to protect them what I'm
trying to do with people teach them how
to find more themselves to where they
empower themselves I'm all about the
underdog rule number 32 change your
internal dialogue the most important
conversation is the one you have with
yourself you wake up with it you walk
around with it you go to bed with it
eventually you act on it sometimes you
act on it good sometimes bad you got to
change the internal dialogue that person
in your head that's talking that to you
until you change the internal dialogue
in your head until you callus over the
victims mentality that the world is out
to get you because of you are the only
you got change - man yeah be here
understand my life David yeah I do
the thing about it and that's why I can
talk about but yeah I give your saying a
lot of folks don't I get that mentality
I once had that mentality that no one
understands what I'm going through and
if you keep that mentality you're gonna
stay in the same exact spot that you're
in that no one understands me there's a
whole there's millions of people why do
you think a book that I saw published
you know it's doing so well with your
story that's so dope you're like I'll
never give up I went to a publishing
house like who's gonna resonate with
this story no one's gonna buy this book
I'm like are you not in the world are
you not in society you're never alone
everybody's going through so when people
get this mentality of like you
understand me you can throw a lock to
someone that can understand you if
they're willing to break themselves down
and stop hiding a lot of people
understand you mmm but you got to stop
hiding and that's why I tell people a
lot of people are going through that is
hide better than you did that's all they
did it was hiding better rule number 33
be brutally honest we live in the world
now that's so kind we we find the kind
way around everything like if you don't
look good I have to find a kind way of
saying I don't like your shirt
right that's not the approach if that's
the approach you're looking for that
book is not for you you can't hurt me is
not for you the approach you have to
take at least I took you take whatever
proach you want the conversation had to
be a real honest conversation in the
accountability mirror guess what I was
fat don't find a kind word to say that
you know what I've gained some weight no
you're fat when I couldn't read not like
a you know even learn disability no I
cannot read of a fourth grade reading
level I'm struggling and sometimes I
call myself stupid not in a way to put
myself down so don't take it like my god
those are so hard yeah the hurtful this
honest the conversation has to become an
honest conversation of where you're at
mentally where I'm at mentally I look
like I feel like
I'm not this I'm falling behind in
school I'm lazy
my house is a mess you have to look at
what it is and call it what it is don't
find words to make yourself feel better
because that's what
so we hang around people that make us
feel better that tell us what we want to
hear not what we need to hear and so we
stay away from those people and we stay
away from those people like our internal
dialogue becomes that kind it's ok it's
not ok so that's where it starts it
starts with that accountability of it's
not okay anymore this can no longer be
okay and calling yourself out for
exactly what you are in exactly how you
need to fix it rule number 34 believe as
you know I'm a serious introvert and
very afraid of people I got just so much
growing up that this is uncomfortable
for me all these podcasts male that's
why I post once a week yeah I don't you
know people are ugly people are nasty
they make me want to choke the [ __ ] out
of him and they're just nasty people so
I stay away from them but the one thing
I realized why I wrote the book is
honestly I have a story to tell as we
all have a story to tell and what I
realized on my journey was a lot of us
don't believe that we can achieve the
impossible and along my journey I
started realizing man I got tell some
people about this man like I discover
something that some people have but they
don't even know all of us have it but
along this way I wasn't like I said I
wasn't a theorist I became a
practitioner and I was like my god I'm
busting down so many barriers of like I
have a learning disability
okay well I'm catching up with everybody
I heard that out I figured out all these
negative things in my life that were
keeping me in this hole like I gotta
tell people man that hang on a second
man you can achieve the absolute
impossible rule number 35 celebrate your
victories
you are pretty good about celebrating
the victories along the way and
celebrating yourself I talk about with
my fiancee every single day I talked
about with her two hours today I said we
are grinding so hard that we are losing
the vantage point of what we have
accomplished today we got podcast
podcast interview flying do this do that
like stop stop it's just me and you
and this mom-and-pop thing that we that
we're doing look at what this book is
that right now
it's crazy look how many people were
touching shut shut up
and this think for a second I stopped
because all we did was talk about this
and this really I don't know enjoy this
for a second let's we have to take time
it rule out what the we've accomplished
that's an evolution for you man huge
huge but it's a very different David
Goggins and even from a couple years ago
huge because you have to where's all
about I'm gonna keep on grinding that's
not what I'm saying what I'm saying
though is you have to respect what
you've done
take a second not live in it not sit
around and say I'm good
sit back and say let me look at the
vantage point now that I'm at we went
there that's why you reset the vantage
point get the tactical advantage if you
get the tactical advantage to quick and
start fighting you got to take a second
to take observation that where I'm at
what have I done I'm on the right spot
I'm obviously in the right spot right
now now we can go back to fighting rule
number 36 don't overthink things I get a
lot of questions about how I lost so
much weight people want to know how they
can get started so basically you're
thinking two months off the bat run lost
my weight I look for a trainer I ain't
do all that thinking I didn't go on
Jenny Craig I didn't do all that what I
do is I basically stop eating so much
food I cut my calories down so as far as
the workout goes we overthink that also
until you find a trainer go out there
and start walking
put some shoes on start running go to
the gym do the elliptical trainer it's
not rocket science a lot of folks talk
about overtraining
you got trained first before you can
over trained sometimes you wake up in
the morning time in your sword and you
think you're over trained no you got
sore legs get out your old head they
stop overthinking it rule number 37
don't forget your roots
the world is so fast-paced the water is
so noisy
so my conversation now a lot of times is
my god slow down the world can take you
here here be here be there be everywhere
and I lose myself sometimes so I catch
myself in the airport I catch myself in
the playing around writing stuff down
okay remember this room in that locker
hey hey on second Goggins what got you
here this isn't what got you here slow
the down go back to the quiet place of
that dirty mirror in that seven dollar
month place used to live in that's where
you grew you so I so that's what I'm
constantly reminding myself we'll go
back to your roots now I'm not saying go
back to hell I'm saying don't forget
where you come from as you start to
explode out of the gate when you become
someone my conversation is do not forget
your roots do not forget your roots
don't let this become so big that you
lose yourself amongst the noise go back
to the quietness of what made you
successful
rule number 38 don't lose yourself I
used to hate people not liking me when
the hardest things in the world for me
at a young age was my god I swore to fit
in I want to fit in I want you to like
me so that's a horrible place to be in
life because you lose yourself when you
want to fit in with people so badly
normal people know better than you you
do whatever you can to fit in that's a
bad place to be you lose yourself and
trying to create a character that other
people will accept and the that's what I
found a lot enjoy man this is guy
is me not speaking the third personal
tip I got some going on still working on
myself take your leave you don't like me
take a number and get in line man
rule number 39 being relatable the
motivation where people are losing all
these people who come out here and talk
about how great they are and I see it
all time makes me sick man get real with
yourself
people cannot relate to you man you are
unrelatable when you come out here and
say hey man I'm the baddest never live
okay great well I what am I going to
learn from you you learn from people who
are willing to tell you this is where I
started from this is how much I fell on
my ass this is how bad I used to really
be I still have those moments cuz why
you're human we're all jacked up man
we're all jacked up and that's what
makes my story relatable I willing to
let you in to see I'm decently
successful now I didn't come out like
this man I didn't come out that's the
story is you have to give people just a
little bit of hope there's no hope when
they see greatness in you everywhere you
have to be able to get yourself down to
a level of check it out man there's hope
for you that's what I'm trying to give
you just a little bit
rule number 40 stop making excuses so
what's your Excuse it's a Tuco where you
live is it too hot where you live does
it rain too much nice power sunroof talk
maybe you're the only black person
applying for a job maybe the only female
maybe the only gay person job whatever
it may be maybe that's in your head
maybe that's your excuse for not being
better life's a real big picture when I
was young all those things got my head
black not smart enough single mom all
that bull oh space in my head if you're
allowing people and things the
situation's choice patient then you're
losing last thing last one big head game
you play with yourself if you lose it's
because you allow life to get in your
head stay hard
rule number 41 push yourself to the
extreme when I got through with that
first hundred mile race that I did
around that one-mile track that I didn't
prepare for and I was considerably it
was horrible
and I'll never forget I found such peace
and beauty and I got there I was in the
worst pain in my life and I got done and
my wife pulled the car up on the my ex
wife pulled the car up on this little
lawn and I got in the back of it and I
got the stairs I'm not gonna go through
the whole story but I remember laying in
the in the tub
and she put the shower on me and I ran a
hundred one miles like 19 hours and I
was like peeing dirt out of me and I'm
sitting there and I'm jackhammering and
my body is just the most broken has ever
been even to this day and this feeling
came over me call it crazy if you want
but very few people I guarantee ever
felt this before to push themselves so
far outside of what they thought was
even possible even for me I laid in that
tub and I didn't want it to go away
I had drained myself of every bit of
strength energy I had and it was the
best feeling ahead of my life
all that pain it was it was confirmation
it was confirmation that I had gone
through a crucible and I have figured
out
another level of david Goggins a level
that i thought was humanly impossible
for anybody to do when I was at Mile 70
and pissed all over myself and had 30
more miles to go and I was damn near
dead and I was able to go 31 more miles
in that process of the next 31 more
miles I found out more about myself in
that 31 miles than ever had in my entire
life
the conversations the mental blocks the
roadblocks to everything horrible it was
just feeding at me like Lightspeed get
the out of here man like I was able to
figure out different tactics and when I
finally got done with that I laid in
that tub and it was over the feeling of
my god man you just really discovered a
whole new world a whole new part of the
brain that guarantee very few people
have
rule number 42 tap into suffering so
thing about I say suffering people
cringe people that thought that's the
one word whenever I post about it people
cringe
it's not about suffering how people may
look at suffering like you had to dish
go to a place that's just every day of
your life is suffering you have to tap
into suffering every day of your life
because we have so much scarring that we
have to clean up you have to look at
suffering as almost like I look at
failure to succeed you must fail in
failure and in suffering all the answers
are in there all the answers to all the
test questions the test is your life all
the answers are in there you have to
live in suffering and pain and failure
all the time you have to learn I need to
visit it like people hate working out
you're only gonna visit working out
maybe an hour a day 23 other hours of
the day you're not in it hmm but how you
become in shape is you must visit
suffering visits working out one hour a
day visit suffering one hour a day visit
your past failures one hour a day the
relationship with it is the answers are
in there they they are in there
within the suffering go in there and I
call it the live autopsy the live
autopsy how do you find out someone died
they crack you open after you're dead
how you can live is do it while you're
alive
go back in your brain crack it open
while you're alive don't wait until
you're dead to figure out why you died
do it why you are living go in there go
into the suffering go into the pain of
your life and say why did this suck for
me so bad why am I afraid of all this
stuff why am I shut down the whole world
I guarantee I'll tell you why you shut
down the whole world it's in these nooks
of the suffering within your brain in
the scarring are all the answers to why
you are on the couch feeling sorry for
yourself they lie within the scars visit
them for at least an hour a day study
them and then you'll find out more about
yourself you will then grow so don't
look at it every day I suffer go into it
an hour a day learn from yourself learn
from life learn from your failures learn
from your insecurities learn from your
self-doubt don't just say I'm afraid to
jump out of an airplane hmm what makes
you afraid of it study it that's why I
studied my mind why became so powerful
in the mind because I realized I was
weak so instead of running away from the
mind
I'd open to and say what is making me
weak oh this makes sense I came from
hell I came from a place that beat me
down to nothing which is why I'm afraid
all this makes sense
so systemically one by one I went back
and met every single person in my mind
every situation I went one-on-one with
them again in my mind it's okay that's
now revisit this and that's how you do
it
that's how it works rule number 43 study
your days I write down my day and what I
do is I go back and study that day like
sometimes I might I might get sick I
might be over trained I might gain a
couple pounds here I might feel it
whatever that and I it's like my
accountability journal of what I'm doing
with my life
physical mental I had an eating Journal
all this and helped me go back to once
again study I'm a lab rat and I studied
myself I'm like not feeling up I go okay
what I do last week and usually I can
find out where I messed up last week you
know how much time travel I want some
sleep and how much I'm doing all this
stuff and and through journaling man you
can really figure out so much about
where you're messing up in life and what
you need to fix about yourself taking
constant inventory costing honest about
that and that's thing about you cannot
put bull in there yeah it's gotta be a
real a real journal about a today I
messed up here today I should have been
a better person here and not just saying
it but actually trying to fix it
tomorrow
rule number 44 do things your way i sat
back and I had the top five people come
at me top five publishing houses and
it's down to the last two and they're
offering $300,000 I'm a first time you
know first time author and I decided to
go with one of them and $300,000 for a
guy at me I'm Sinbad you know that's
pretty good money so a few days before I
was gonna sign the contract I sat back
talk to my fiance my family and
everybody's like you know hey you know
this is good this is great whatever but
I started thinking about my life I
started thinking about everything that
I've gone through my life everything I
had gone through it had a chance to
reflect and that's one thing I never did
in my life long enough is have time to
reflect I was always what's next what's
next what's next what's next what's next
now that I'm retired and you have a lot
of time to look back on what you've done
where you started where you're at now
and I said you know what it's not for
sale $300,000 isn't even a fraction of
enough money to sell this so I decided
not to sign it and I saw published I
pissed a lot of people off
and I said I'm not signing this I'm
going to self-publish and that's kind of
how it came to be I took that time to
reflect and I'd rather not make a dime I
wrote this book and that's honest to
God's truth
I'm fine with the trophy I have in my
mind
rule number 45 constantly evolved I
never set out to write a book when I was
in the dungeon and no one was coming
back to help me I just wanted that
reflection in that accountability mirror
that I hate it so badly to be something
that gave me pride to be something that
made me feel it wanted but it's not
about money it's not about success isn't
about people I'm not godless david
Goggins sign my book
No when I started this journey out years
ago it's about I just want to learn to
read so now I'm at a place now where I
see the possibilities of the human of
human potential
what are we capable of it's a
conversation now the conversation now is
how can I now talk to people in a way
they can understand the message that I
have for so many people for so many
people so that's it that's the new
conversation now is that I you are
constantly evolving
you never say you're getting better
you're getting worse not staying the
same hmm so for me after constantly be
getting better I think honestly be
evolving my message so I'm constantly
thinking in the quietness of my mind
rule number 46 be the best you can be
honestly my biggest fear to this day is
um and I say it a lot and I say a lot
and it is it's going to heaven and being
judged by God and you know God has I
believe that God has this knows
everything about you from time you're
born when you can be born when you're
gonna die we need a graduate buzz
whatever's gonna happen - he knows all
these some people never do what God
knows you're capable of doing cuz you
keep in here we have choices my biggest
fear in life was to was to get to heaven
and God look at me as I'm being judged
and I was some fat 300-pound guy like I
used to be that still is pray for
cockroach it was a car you know that's
that's all case what you want to do I
didn't want to do that and I made a
thousand dollars you know a month I got
to heaven and God laid out this chart in
front of me and they said hey man look
at this chart it had my name on top and
all the
amazing and like that's not that's not
me man because that's who you were
supposed to be my biggest fear in life
is that one day if I ever get judged by
something someone some some energy force
that go up there and I failed the
mission whatever would ever force up
their thought Austen was to be some
badass and I went up there underachieved
you know I want that force up there that
knows everything to be writing as I'm
living and saying I had no idea he even
had this in him so I want to just be the
best I can and a lot people say that I
truly mean that
rule number 47 be happy with who you are
I realized this it's not about money
it's not about Fame it's not about being
accepted by your peers and everybody
else it's about figuring out who I am
and being happy with who the [ __ ] I am
even though I'm gonna be judged for all
these things be done to put a middle
finger up to everybody and say this is
David Goggins and to get to that point
it felt great
rule number 48 tap into your mind don't
do everything in your life for money
don't do everything yes we needed to
survive there's a great Drive and
passion behind doing things for the mind
in the soul is a great Drive in that
everybody man you you talk with such
passion this is a life this is my life
so that's so that's what I want people
to get from all this stuff man like
there's something inside you the the
brain is the most powerful thing the
minds most powerful thing that we have
it's not your phone something computer
it's not anything
it's your mind and if you can tap into
that you can come from the from the
daggone roots of hell and become such a
great seed a policy that can grow into
some great daggone garden and people
don't get that it's all up here
the power and the magics up here rule
number 49 find your purpose and if you
don't believe that you're here for a
reason your life will seriously hurt and
I start looking at my life and all this
I went through as God put me some guy
every believed in put me here to go
through this and I see all the hundreds
of thousands of lives I'm changing by
the hell I went through there's a lot of
power in that so my purpose as I started
going through this journey instead of
looking like woe is me god man why the
man what why I said looking at what's
the perfect training ground you knew
exactly what you were doing you know
exactly what you were doing obviously
you put me in every situation possible
to tell a story that needs to be told
and real number 50 the last something
for a very special bonus clip is don't
care what cowards think I get an email
the other day this young man wants to be
a ranger
means afraid to go to Ranger School not
because the heart of the training is but
because he's afraid if he fails what
people are gonna say by judgement one
thing in life its applies to everything
in life anytime you move from being
normal to trying to be exceptional
people aren't gonna like this most
normal people it makes them feel like
she'll judge you and nowadays it's very
easy to be a coward why we've got
instagramers most folks don't tell you
to your face they go online they post
about like cowards to let carers get it
last day make sure you do you stay hard
now I've got a special bonus gift from
David on how to add value that I think
you could enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one where do you need to
be constantly evolving number two what's
suffering can you tap into to get
stronger and number three what extreme
do we need to push yourself to I
deployed I fought in combat stuff like
that first of all it's hard to relate to
that second of all I to get all kind of
approvals from people to get that in the
book and talk about it and I want to go
through that process of hey can I put
you know what I did in Iraq in the book
and stuff like that in the book
and I want my book to relate to people
you know there's enough Navy SEAL books
out there talking about you know running
gun and shooting them up stuff like that
that's never been I don't want to be
known as a Navy SEAL even though I talk
a lot you know people want to ask me
about it you know Navy said that was a
snippet of my life you know I was a
snippet of my life and I want to be
known as somebody much more than that
who did a lot more than that so my book
is about helping people and I can't help
people through what I did in combat
mm-hmm I can help people by what I went
through in life life itself and I went
out to I mean it was it was intentional
to make this book about how can these
stories resonate and help people and you
know it wasn't my cake let me kiss my
own ass if you want more David Goggins
motivation check out their video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you did this wrong you did this
wrong or they get yelled at it's so easy
to be great nowadays because everybody
else is most people are weak